همم نحن لدينا التزام في الشرق الاوسط في
مبادره الخضراء
والمبادره السعوديه الخضراء
يمكننا ان ننظر الى الجميع في هذا الايطار
ونقول اننا نجحنا
وسنواصل ذلك
ودائما المساله مساله ذهنيه
فعندما قال سمو الامير ولي العهد همم
الشيخ محمد واعلن عن المبادره الخضراء
الله يبارك فيك بيهلد قبري وانها ستعقد في
فاعليه سنويه هذا لاننا يجب ان نكون
مسؤولين ونحن نريد هذه المسؤوليه وكلنا
ثقه
باننا لانه مانع ان نكون
تحت تدقيق الاخرين
طموحين وملتزمين يجب
نتراجع عن عقدي مثل هذه الفعاليات سنويا
وهذا انتقال جيد يجعل هذين المؤتمرين
يتصادفان مع القبض ولا العام القادم سيكون
لدينا مبادره
همم
المبادره همم السعوديه وكوب في الامارات
ودول اخرى ستستطيع في المستقبل ستواصل
كاونتبل اييه محاسباتنا على هذه الانجازات
وهذه الفعاليات التي تتصادف مع مؤتمر
الكوب
نبدي لكم ما انجزناه في تحقيقه
وعودنا امامي
لا استطيع
الفورميسو
كل شيء مسبقا لكنني احب ان اكون ارتجاليا
ولا احب ان اقرا من الورق
ومن المثير ان نرى كل هذا الانجاز وهذا
يعكس كل ما انجزناه حتى الان فنحن
من الشباب والنساء السعوديه والقياده
والتزام هذه القياده وكل من يعملون مع
القياده بس ليست فقط الحكومه بل المؤسسات
المؤسسات الدوله والمجتمع والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه وكل الاطراف المعنيه في الدوله
فكلما طالت القائمه كل ما عرضنا هذا
الالتزام استحملوني
ارجع
وفرنسائي
بمحاسبتنا منذ العام الماضي انتم طالبتم
بذلك فحصلتم عليه تحملوني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الذي اعلن عنه العام الماضي
يعتمد على التكنولوجيا نحن نؤمن بانها بان
هذا سيحقق في وقت اقرب
لكن عندما نلتزم نريد ان نضمن ان يكون
وفاءنا تامرنا هو ان نحقق هذا الانجاز قبل
الوقت
كما كان الفيديو قد بين
17 ايه
ار اتش
78 مليون
نعمل
بثقه للوصول الى ذلك الرقم
المتجدده
[موسيقى]
او تعملي
مليون طن من ثاني اكسيد الكربون و13
همم مشروع اضافي لهذا القطار
وتوقتها همم 11.4 جيجا وات
وبال
سيقلل نحو 20
21 21 مليون
اورينيو بالفرنس
على الجوائز دوليه لافضل
كافضل منصه
وجائزتين الدوليتين
والعامل القادم
لتطوير عشر مشاريع طاقه متجدده اضافيه